the fact is all ancient cultures were
horribly brutal in our standards
campaigns of Alexander the so-called
great on mentioned by Boris The Athenian
massacre at Milos unmentioned by Boris
and the wars of Julius Caesar and Gaul
understandably unmentioned by Boris
seemed to me to make a pretty much a
scored draw when it comes to sheer
nastiness
and even the Greeks by the way as soon
as they discovered gladiatorial games
they went for them absolutely
fantastically and they converted all
their nice stadia into gladiatorial
arenas
but happily this isn't they did I'll
show you what in Ephesus wonders
but this isn't a contest in niceness
because if it were we might not find a
winner